[Musik]
sie kommen aus polen aus deutschland
oder ungarn und sorgen dafür dass alte
und pflegebedürftige menschen in der
schweiz in ihrer gewohnten umgebung
bleiben können
[Musik]
nur weg sie kochen putzen waschen haare
und verbinden auch mal ein bein und
nachts sind sie nicht nur im notfall
erreichbar sondern schlafen im zimmer
nebenan immer einsatzbereit 24 stunden
lang
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie fällt nicht länder bereisen
[Musik]
haben sie fertige haare haben ja man
kann
haben sie schon der locken gehört ja
[Musik]
sogar dezimiert die schön gleichmäßig
ein bisschen massage hast du gut das
wichtigste in dieser beruf ist das herz
die liebe vertrauen respekt miteinander
das ist das wichtigste und die nähe
wärme zu geben an den menschen das
volunteer doch jeder haben
der kauf springe wieder jungs wissen ja
lange hat ruth mädchen ihren mann helmut
selbst gepflegt seit einem halben jahr
hilft ihr berliner dom ansgar dabei sie
ist eine von geschätzten 30.000 privat
pflegerinnen in der schweiz und seit der
eu-osterweiterung werden es immer mehr
morena stammt aus polen und arbeitet
seit 20 jahren als pflege betreuerin im
ausland erst in deutschland und seit
zwei jahren in der schweiz in basel
ich kenne diese berufszeit meine
kindheit von zuhause meine mutter hat
die großmutter zu hause betreut
und wir haben alle zusammen gelegt und
hab ich gesehen wie mutter das macht und
wie würde ich das machen
und plötzlich später wer nicht so so
patienten gehabt habe h ich wusste ich
kann das ich verstehe dass ich verstehe
warum so ist warum die menschen verwehrt
sind was kann das sein was das für
krankheit sein kann
also ich denke das hat mich vorbereitet
aber erst später habe ich das entdeckt
und halten sie mich an die hand wenn sie
angst haben
ich kriege auch viel lieber zurück und
ich fühle mich die wichtigste auf dieser
welt und das ist das schöne
das ist das schöne dass ich für diese
personen bin ich jemand besonderes auch
so so das selbe fasst die fohlen also
wie wir schenken uns gegenseitig das
vertrauen nun dass das herz endlich da
schön wäre ja jetzt wie jetzt ich bin
dass das ganz wichtige chance konto
familie sie und drehe bespricht und
verständnis spricht und da ich so
dankbar und das seht was man eigentlich
alles soweit und wir haben so viele
schöne stunden
als ich hätte gar nicht messen und so
lang dass es gott möchte ich das
wirklich
ich hoffe ich hatte auf der zellstoff
gesund leben
[Musik]
was tun wenn alte menschen nicht mehr
für sich selbst sorgen können
wenn die kranke ehefrau oder der
gebrechliche vater plötzlich viel pflege
brauchen und wäre damit überfordert sind
sollen wir das eigene leben auf den kopf
stellen oder dass der dementen mutter
[Musik]
klarer wird ist 85 jahre alt und vor gut
acht jahren an alzheimer erkrankt vor
einem jahr suchte ihre tochter im
internet nach einer 24 stunden betreuung
so fand sie eva palffy aus ungarn
eva war ihr leben lang lehrerin in einem
kleinen dorf zwei stunden südlich von
budapest
es ist ihre erste stelle als betreuerin
die schweiz könnte sie nur von
postkarten und bildern aus dem internet
für mich war es komisch dass hier in der
schweiz für alte leute ins heim gehen
hauptsächlich also ich glaub 99 prozent
bestimmt ich weiß es nicht ganz genau
weil bei uns in ungarn ist es ganz
anders
das ist ganz verständlich dass die die
kinder ihr tempo an
und wenn ich daran denke dass diese
menschen jahrzehntelang in einem eigenen
haus gelebt haben
mit den eigenen kindern also die
atmosphäre zärtlichkeit lebe das haben
sie bestimmt in einem altersheim nicht
[Musik]
eva ball viel arbeitet hier in alf armee
am bielersee drei wochen durch und
pendelt dann für eine woche zurück nach
ungarn
dafür verdient sie knapp 3000 franken
ein vielfaches von dem was die
ausgebildete lehrerin in ihrem
heimatland kriegt als ich hierher kam da
wusste ich wirklich nicht was auf mich
wartet ganz genau
das haus ist ziemlich groß in der daten
ist kurz und klar ist auch ziemlich
schwierig mit der betreuung hatte ich
überhaupt keine erfahrungen
ich habe nur gehört wie das die anderen
machen und da ich sehr sehr lange mehr
als 30 jahre unterrichtet habe dann habe
ich gedacht dass ich also wenn ich mit
menschen gut umgehen konnte bisher in
der schule dann sollte es doch klappen
das geht ja wiederum menschen ist nicht
für dich um
das ist ganz klar die wollen sie jetzt
salat schneiden salat schneiden wollen
ich bin merke oft dass ich meine
erfahrungen was ich kinder schule
gemacht habe man den kindern die wie ein
bisschen schwierig waren wie kann ich
brauche man muss ein wenig manchmal
schlau sein und ein bisschen anders mit
den problemen die alzheimer krankheit
hat viele gesichter und ihr verlauf ist
bei jedem patienten anders
die erkrankten wissen zwar vieles nicht
mehr
das bedeutet aber nicht dass sie nichts
mehr verstehen
das zu erkennen braucht kraft und
aufmerksamkeit was angehörige und
betreuerinnen überfordern kann aufgrund
ihrer inneren zerrüttung geht den
patienten das gefühl der geborgenheit
verloren
sie sehnen sich nach einem zuhause das
es nicht mehr gibt selbst in den eigenen
vier wänden nicht zurück bleibt eine
große irritation
[Musik]
gold ok
juliana und schwierigsten war für mich
die aggressivität also klar weil ich
könnte sagen ein jahr lang bestimmt
regelmäßig aggressiv regelmäßig bei
dieser krankheit und wenn das mit
aggressivität zusammen ist dann kann man
nie wissen wann es passiert sie ist zum
beispiel ganz gut gelaunt und auf einmal
sieht sie dass es regnet und dann bin
ich schuld daran man kann sich darauf
nicht vorbereiten
am anfang konnte ich so kochen das
zehnter mir stand und also ich konnte
sie nicht sehen und sie hat damit mit
dem topf auf meinen rücken
man spaziert dann hat sie oft mit den
stöcken geschlagen
in mein gesicht gespuckt und kratzt also
dass daran alles mögliche ich weiß auch
wenn sie will dann ist wenn sie
aggressiv ist das ist die krankheit und
nicht sie und ich glaube das hat auch
viel geholfen dass ich dieser dieser
periode ein bisschen bestehen konnte
soll ich sagen ich weiß salat gerade
soll ich da
gerade hat schon gegessen hat schon das
nach platz
[Musik]
das geschafft hat so für und tritte und
mir somit langsamer gemacht und und
nicht plötzlich auf der münchner messe
wie häufig eingeschränkt
jetzt macht das extrakt ist eine folge
falscher so sicherlich einige
schlitzwand ergangen als nicht
akzeptieren und edith und gleich alle so
hilflos und und dgb
[Musik]
und wonach die vier jahre lang wurde
peter libori von der ungar in ildiko
aber gepflegt bis in den tod
seither sind ildiko und christine
freundinnen geworden
mittlerweile hat ildiko eine neue stelle
in der schweiz angenommen
doch wenn sie zeit hat besucht sie
christine in die kreuzung gartenhaus
leonie kennt gar nie und der hygiene
nach ungarn nagelt ja ich gehe 14 tag
für 14 tage zum proben oder wusste ich
ja wirklich die familie habe ich weiß
dass er mich geschätzt rang er hat mich
nie beleidigt ich war mit mir nie groß
er hat mich so akzeptiert wie billig und
das ist eine zeichnung auch für mich was
ich mache das das mache ich vielleicht
gut also aus was houten mit pflege- und
erleben und duschen und waschen und
zähneputzen mit einem pelikan nicht
konfrontiert sie also heißt es wirklich
schöne sie können mit minimal ab und
verletzte trio was sie mir schlecht
gegangen ist nicht wissen wo das hatte
im flecken ihr kam der schöne momente
maxis morgens mittags und wachstums sind
garten oder im moment der wollten womit
er realisiert gleich noch für
zurück in basel
jeden sonntag findet in der
allerheiligenkirche eine polnische
messestadt ein wichtiger ankerpunkt für
die betreuerinnen die hier regelmäßig
zusammenkommen und sich austauschen
diesen sonntag sorgt ein trauerfall für
gesprächsstoff der sich im tessin
zugetragen hat eine polnische betreuerin
hat sich das leben genommen
niemand weiß genau was geschehen ist
laut polizeibericht hatte die 56-jährige
bereits ein ticket für die busreise nach
hause wo ihr bruder und ihre alte mutter
auf sie warteten
mittlerweile sind die polizeilichen
ermittlungen eingestellt und die polin
wurde in einem sack in ihre heimat
überstellt
[Musik]
werner domann scart trifft sich nach der
messe mit ein paar kolleginnen im
gemeindesaal um über den vorfall zu
sprechen
eine blonde haare und da habe ich nach
meinem angezeigt habe ich geschaut dass
ich diese polin war hat sie schon
gedacht war genial einfach psychisch
fangen ja und dieser probleme dort dass
die leute haben so viel druck gemacht
und ich die oma die sie betreut hat hat
30.000 die haben so druck gehabt die
haben behauptet dass sie was geklaut hat
und sie war sehr gläubig und katholisch
und hat noch so ein druck und von der
familie und wird kontrolliert gesperrt
kontrolliert das unglaubliche 24 stunden
immer im gleichen sich sarah sie
irgendwo polizei der schweizer leute die
glauben ihre nicht vielleicht das ist
sauer ich glaube dass sich auf das wir
sind einfach wie eine zweite kategorie
hier
wir arbeiten mit herz du gibst alles
liebe und manche leute sagen mir du bist
einfach vergeben geld her gekommen
ja das ja das auch vielleicht die
scheiben sich sie will nicht sagen wie
war sie behandeln ist auch nicht alles
zu hause wenig und er würde ich habe
schwierigkeiten kämen einige gut ich
alles gut und alles das ist auch und
vielleicht sie hat auch nicht zumute und
kraft gehabt dass sie muss sagen nein
mir geht nicht gut ich schaffe das nicht
ist kann man zurück nach polen und die
leute wussten dass wir sind bei
schwierigen situation und die nutzen
dass das wir sind hier einfach wegen
arbeit gehen weil wir brauchen das
schade dass die frau zum beispiel hat
nie geschickt jemanden 1 1 sms hilft es
war eine kollegin die halbe stunde vorn
gerufen hat aber sie hat sich schon
blockiert nein das will nicht mehr
ich habe jetzt genug ich will von
niemand was jetzt es genug mein schmerz
mein group ist
und oft ist so ich kann es verstehen ich
habe es erlebt wo meine krug voll ist
und hab ich gesagt jetzt muss ich
aufhören mit 24 stunden job weil ich
brauche luft ich brauche meine freiheit
der ein bisschen mehr zeit für mich
[Musik]
seit ein paar monaten arbeitet bazina
domains kann nicht mehr als 24 stunden
betreuerin
sie hat sich in basel niedergelassen und
einen pflegefonds belegt jetzt arbeitet
sie für eine private spitex agentur und
betreut verschiedene patienten einsatz
weise nicht immer verläuft die
zusammenarbeit mit den agenturen
reibungslos der junge markt boomt in der
schweiz und ist unreguliert
anstellungsbedingungen und entlohnungen
variieren stark
der letzte arbeitgeber hat morgen
während monaten angehäuften überstunden
nicht ausbezahlt daraufhin hat bosch
etwas gemacht was vor ihr noch keine
ausländische betreuerin getan hat sie
hat gegen ihren arbeitgeber klage
eingereicht
das war mein geld das von meinem geld
was mir zusteht was ich verdient habe
das war meine zeit das war meine arbeit
das war meine nächste sich bei dieser
für patient verbracht habe warum soll
ich das geld schenken darstellt mir doch
zu und schweiz ist die gerechtigkeit
land
da habe ich gesagt jetzt hatte nie ich
haue ab oder ich kämpfe ganz ohne anwalt
hat burma ihre klage eingereicht und den
inhaber der agentur so vor dem
schlichtungsrat gezwungen es war für
mich schwierig aber habe ich geschafft
und hab ich gewonnen und arbeitgeber
musste bezahlen
er hat auch an uns auch gutes geld
verdient und das war keine respekt und
deswegen habe ich keine mitleid wegen
ihm dass ich das gemacht habe wenn ich
damals mit angst nach hause gefahren
hätte und mit weinen und und noch so
weiter ich habe schon gedacht was würde
ich in polen machen
ja ich hab stück land vielleicht die
himbeeren pflanzen hat etwa so aber das
reicht nicht ich musste noch da sein ich
muss meine tochter zeigen dass so viele
jahre dass ich noch was er unternehmen
kann dass ich meine tochter bessere
leben aufbauen kann
[Musik]
bürger heft souvenier halte ich habe
ausschnitte heimschlappe
und da bin ich frei doch in die frei
kruschel uhr gehängt und fühle ich mich
hier umschaue vor der brave probleme
[Gelächter]
sie führe mehr haben um sport ihr und
wenn ich schon wartet auf seine anker
auch eine brave frau das nur sagen und
auch avatar die anderen epoche und wenn
sie hat ja immer so er hat doch nur dank
der jugend sieht dass sie mal ein paar
polnische wörter ich weiß noch mehr
diese nicht immer ganz schön
[Musik]
wir hatten mehrere kredite und fünf
kinder drei haben wir schon studiert und
das kostet unheimlich viel zeit
ein haus gebaut und wegen das dem
studium wegen das raus wir mussten immer
kredit aufnehmen von einem kredit ins
andere
und dann hatten wir schlussendlich
parallel mäder der kredite und das kinn
finanzieren nicht mehr
[Musik]
harter ein kleines dorf im süden ungarns
weil es im achtzehnten jahrhundert von
deutschen auswanderern besiedelt wurde
sprechen die leute hier zum teil immer
noch deutsch
das kommt den frauen zugute die als
pflegerinnen in deutschland österreich
oder in der schweiz arbeiten und das tun
hier die meisten und bis auf ein paar
wenige ausnahmen
tun sie es schwarz
viele frauen arbeiten illegal und sie
danken überhaupt nicht daran was ist
später mit mit ihrem rentenwerte ob sie
geld bekommen nachher
sie freuen sich dass sie überhaupt
arbeit haben die frauen kennen sich gut
untereinander
sie sind vernetzt und vermitteln sich
die stellen gegenseitig so wechseln sich
töchter mit schwiegermüttern cousinen
mit schwägerinnen und mütter mit
großmüttern ab man kennt sich und das
macht die sache einfacher in der schweiz
in bellach wenn ich irgendwelche
probleme habe darauf wie sie an und wir
sprechen miteinander
also was das was die betreuung betrifft
oder medikamente oder ist egal was für
probleme
wir haben sehr guter kontakt zueinander
in dem haus ist eine junge frau nach
deutschland gefahren also sie betreute
in deutschland und sie hat es waren
kleine kinder hier gelassen
die kinder gehen noch in den
kindergarten das hat mir die
kindergärtnerin erzählt dass sie ganz
ganz sich verlangt haben die kinder und
sie sprechen nur über die mutter sie
vermissen sie sehr wenn ich nach hause
komme dann muss ich diese aber
weitermachen
jena vermögen der schweiz nur ich muss
alles während dieser einer woche machen
also das bedeutet dass ich wirklich viel
viel viel mehr machen muss und ich gehe
oft serie a zurück die hohe
arbeitslosigkeit trifft das ländliche
ungarn besonders schwer
viele sind verschuldet und leben von
krediten die sie nicht zurückzahlen
können
evas mann ist auch lehrer sie haben fünf
kinder
agnes die jüngste tochter steht kurz vor
der matura nebst wäscheberg und anderen
haus arbeiten stehen jetzt erstmal
nachhilfestunden für die deutschprüfung
an
wir sprechen oft per skype miteinander
aber das ist nicht dasselbe sie ist dann
auch auch woanders mit den gedanken und
ich kann nicht wirklich über meine
probleme sprechen
sind die kartoffeln schon fertig
sie fehlten schon egal ob beim essen
oder einkaufen
früher war sie einfach immer da aber
jetzt ist sie schon länger weg und wir
haben uns sagen wir mal dran gewöhnt
bist du deine bewerbungen nicht auch auf
deutsch und englisch übersetzen und gibt
es hier auf dem amt keine arbeit für
dich musst du dafür extra nach budapest
es gibt hier keine arbeit
ich fragte ich bin nicht wütend auf sie
es war ihre entscheidung weg zu gehen
sie macht das alles wegen uns um uns
über die runden zu bringen
es ist wie es ist
meine eltern müssen das irgendwie
hinkriegen
hat sich die beziehung deine eltern
verändert seitdem seine mutter weg ist
die beziehung meine eltern hat sich
verschlechtert
meinen vater nimmt das ganze sehr mit
das macht mir sorgen
und deshalb ist es auch für mich
schwierig ich mach das nicht nur wegen
des geldes sondern auch für mich selbst
ich will mir beweisen dass ich meiner
familie helfen kann dass ich dazu
alleine fähig bin
das klingt ein wenig verrückt aber mir
ist das wichtig seit ich 50 geworden bin
brodelt etwas in mir dass ich was
anderes tun muss etwas verändern will
die meisten hier in der umgebung finden
mit 20 eine stelle und bleiben da bis
zur portionierung die wenigsten kündigen
schon gar nicht jetzt in diesen schweren
zeiten in ungarn die meisten die im
ausland arbeiten finden ja hier keine
stelle ich aber habe gekündigt weil ich
etwas anderes wollte vor der rückreise
an den bielersee holt eva palffy nach
wozu ihr in der schweiz sowohl die zeit
als auch das nötige kleingeld fehlt
was meinst du wie viele frauen im dorf
arbeiten als betreuerinnen im ausland
genau weiß ich das nicht aber ich
schätze ungefähr 200 das ist eine ganze
menge den schweizer ich schaue mich in
der schweiz oft nach anderen stellen um
im internet aber es ist sehr schwierig
und wer weiß ob es woanders besser ist
ich bleibe lieber da wo ich bin
es ist jetzt auch schon besser geworden
und ich habe viel dabei gelernt
[Musik]
noch habe ich zum glück meine arbeit
hier und ich bin froh dass so viele
betreuerinnen im ausland arbeiten so
sind meine besten kundinnen sie kommen
immer wieder weil sie es auch bezahlen
können
für meine kleinste tochter ist es dann
schwierig das bemerke ich sie sieht
eigentlich wie wie ihr vater
darunter leidet die drei söhne die die
verstehen ist
[Musik]
es ist einfacher geworden finanziell
wirklich aber ich darf noch nicht
aufhören wir sind noch nicht so lange
mache ich weiter
auch werner domann ska reist ein paar
mal im jahr nach hause nach lublin ganz
im osten von polen nahe der ukrainischen
grenze von basel aus dauert das 26
stunden zeit genug um sich mit anderen
betreuerinnen auszutauschen
diese frau arbeitet seit zwei jahren in
italien für 400 euro schwarz versteht
sich wie die meisten betreuerinnen
arbeitet sie im monatsrhythmus im
wechsel mit einer anderen betreuerin im
grunde genommen verdient sie also nur
200 euro monatlich
aber das ist besser als gar keine arbeit
sie ist unglücklich weil die
misstrauischen kinder der alten dame die
sie betreut dem kühlschrank mit einem
schloss verriegelt haben
jetzt sucht sie nach einer stelle im
tessin wohin es viele polen zieht die in
italien keine arbeit mehr finden
[Musik]
borner kam kurz nach der wende zum
ersten mal in den westen um gurken und
kartoffeln zu ernten
sie war 24 und hat er eine kleine
tochter die sie für die zeit bei ihren
eltern zurück ließ von da an ging sie
regelmäßig nach deutschland immer wieder
am anfang für einen monat dann für drei
erst für gurken und später für die
pflege
sie sagte immer ich gehe von einem
zuhause ins andere hin und her stolz
eine richtige westlichen geworden zu
sein
stolz aus ihrem kleinen dorf
ausgebrochen zu sein um die welt zu
entdecken ihre tochter wuchs derweil bei
den großeltern auf den hier zur schule
und studierte später in warschau viel
hatten die beiden nicht voneinander im
radio haben wir fremde sprache gehört
und das ist unglaublich noch andere
sprache wie kann man das überhaupt
lernen und jetzt denke ich frau fahren
sind
ich habe das geschafft hätte ich nicht
gedacht hier meine kolleginnen die die
waren nicht so lebens gierig wie ich
diese sind bis jetzt noch die die
bäuerinnen man sich in einem fast leeren
geworden
[Musik]
geblieben ist burma domanski ein kleines
grundstück und das haus ihrer eltern
dass sie hin und wieder besucht um nach
dem rechten zu sehen
seitdem ihre eltern im pflegeheim lieben
[Musik]
corinnas eltern haben mehrere
schlaganfälle erlitten erst der vater
später die mutter zu hause konnten sie
sich nicht mehr selbst versorgen
seither liegen sie hier nebeneinander
auf neun quadratmetern jeden tag meine
liebe mama hier sind blumen für die du
siehst schön aus wie ein geschenk ein
osterhase aus der schweiz das ist gute
schokolade dadurch papier ein
hast du auf mich gewartet
sie ist um jetzt bin ich wieder da im
frühling gehen wir dann nochmals hinaus
aufs feld spazieren ja das ist gar nicht
so schlecht aus
damit deine hände nicht frieren decken
wir sie etwas zu schön und papa ist auch
gut lasiert schau mal mama das gefällt
dir sicher warum siehst du das ist vom
karneval denn da sie gefällt dir
[Musik]
scheint siehst du aus wirklich weinen
nicht
ein schwieriges leben hier aber was
sollen wir tun
pflegepersonal ist mangelware in polen
viele wandern in den westen ab wo sie
für die gleiche arbeit mehr verdienen
so entsteht ein pflegenotstand in
krankenhäusern alters und pflegeheimen
in diesem heim kümmern sich zwei
angestellte um 30 patienten ein hilfs
player und eine köchin die als pflegerin
eingesprungen ist weil sich niemand für
die stelle finden ließ
[Musik]
bazina domanski finanziert die pflege
ihrer eltern indem sie dafür in der
schweiz fremde leute pflegt was absurd
anmutet ist in ihrem fall der einzige
weg
[Musik]
nein
manchmal ein bisschen rüber mama ich
will mich neben dich legen und kuschel
[Musik]
eine betreuung endet in vielen fällen
mit dem tod der patientin die
betreuerinnen verlieren damit aber nicht
nur die stelle sondern nicht selten auch
einen menschen dem sie sich intensiv
gewidmet haben
wenn sie sterben
also ich fühle mich einfach sehr lässig
dann kann ich wirklich nicht viel machen
einfach ich möchte auch meine ruhe haben
und nach hause gehen zu hause ich
spreche gar nicht über diese thema ich
denke niemand kann mich verstehen eine
seite wenn niemand hat das erlebt an der
seite das ist wie ein fluch
wenn ich nicht darüber spreche dann kann
ich vielleicht abdecken
ein zeit lang aber das geht nicht immer
ich wusste dass ich weiß ich habe das
noch nicht richtig gelernt wie kann ich
das verarbeiten
[Musik]
ich erlebe mit klar wie auch schöne
momente natürlich wenn sie liebe ist
dann kann sie sehr sehr lieb sein
wirklich vorgestern morgen hat sie eben
zu mir gesagt du wirst jetzt auch zu uns
und das nach 16 monaten endlich das
finde ich schön
[Musik]
ich habe hier
die 2
nur gebaut diese sich was ich weiß dass
seine situation schwierig ist und das
hört sich komisch an
trotzdem fühle ich mich hier wohl weil
ich ich habe ein ziel ich weiß warum ich
hier bin dass ich nicht vorher gedacht
habe wie schwierig es ist es ist nachher
herausgekommen aber dann wasser ich mich
an ich habe lasse mich nicht ablenken
und sofort bin ich ich weiß nicht
mit den nerven fertig nein ich habe
glück dass ich das ausprobieren kann
meine familie ist in ordnung ich kann
kann ihnen kann sie unterstützen
es ist ein glück für mich wirklich
[Musik]
ja das wird
schlafen sie gut und räumen lassen
ich habe aufgehört
diese 24 stunden betreuung weil
eigentlich ich möchte mein leben leben
nicht leben von von andere
ich möchte meine zu hause haben ich
möchte jetzt zeit mit meiner tochter
verbringen wenn ich das foto sehe dann
wünsche ich mir dass dieser zeit noch
mal zurückkommt und dass ich meine
mädchen wieder bei mir haben kann
jetzt ist sie eine erwachsene frau und
sie fiel dieses mädchen ich will noch
mal dieser mutter zeit genießen und ich
denke dass noch zeit das nachzuholen
etwas etwas
seit kurzem lebt monika thomas cover
ihrer mutter in basel
sie hat in warschau eine ausbildung als
physiotherapeutin abgeschlossen
sie will jetzt erstmal deutsch lernen
und später ihre ausbildung anerkennen
lassen wird hierzulande über die 24
stunden betreuung diskutiert tauchen
schlagwörter wie pflegenotstand
schwarzarbeit und hungerlohn auf ist von
ausbeutung und skrupellosen agenturen
die rede
selten wird darüber gesprochen dass
diese frauen eine wichtige arbeit für
unsere gesellschaft leisten
eine arbeit die wir aus lagern weil wir
sie für diesen lohn nicht leisten wollen
alter menschen wollen je länger je mehr
zu hause bleiben und als individuen
wahrgenommen werden es sind frauen wie
bazina domanski oder eva palffy die
ihnen ein würdevolles altern ermöglichen
indem sie sich zeit nehmen einfach nur
da zu sein
hmm
[Musik]